[Music]  you did the movie uh rock of ages  with tom cruise he was they got to know  tom cruise a little bit there was  something that bothered you about about  tom cruise is that correct firstly he's  a glorious man and he's very kind and  sweet that's what you say if you want to  continue to work in the film industry  right and then  but  i was thinking he's a member of that a  religion called scientology i thought oh  i'm interested in that so every so often  i'd say things like uh oh tom  sometimes i'm a bit lost in life  let's see if he would  try to read it yeah yeah i don't know  read the bible  oh  tom i wish i had a way of thinking more  positively about the future  that man had no interest in getting me  in scientology at all wait so you're  hurt that he didn't recruit you for  scientology if there's a cult that don't  want me i want to know why  [Applause]